nous sommes avec le footballeur aurélien
collin le joueur d'orlando chez lui à
paris bonjour aurélien alors vous jouez
actuellement en irlande où je le disais
précédemment mais en major league soccer
mais avant de parler de votre club
orlando nous allons tout d'abord revenir
sur votre parcours vous êtes originaire
de fonte et le fleury vous avez un
parcours assez atypique
vous avez joué à sedan amiens en espagne
à majorque en grèce au pays de galles au
portugal avant de rejoindre la mls
expliquez-nous un petit peu ce parcours
un peu atypique pour pourquoi ce
parcours atypique en fait au final et
j'ai commencé en france sont deux
formations au stade de reims
ensuite je suis parti à sedan à amiens
où j'ai signé mon premier contrat
stagiaire pro la france n'a pas donné
une chance en professionnel je pensais
que à ce qu aucune chance qu'une chance
n'est pas une opportunité pour jouer en
pro donc j'ai décidé très jeunes de
quitter la france car je suis allé à
mayer que ça s'est bien passé mais
j'étais pas encore dans le groupe pro
100 % et j'ai eu cette opportunité en
écosse pour jouer en premier league
donc je suis parti et ça s'est super
bien passé
après après quelques mois des primaires
que le président donc plus de salaires
donc j'étais obligé de chercher un autre
club je suis parti en grèce comme on
connaît la situation en grèce où les
salaires et sont pas très payer donc
j'ai été obligé encore de chercher un
autre club portugal la même histoire et
d après arrive cette opportunité qui
tombe du ciel des états unis et c'est
pas trop déstabilisant pour un jeune
joueur parce qu'au final vous étiez
jeune à l'époque jeune après 29 ans
aujourd'hui vous visitiez je n'avais pas
versée ouais c'était c'était difficile
après j'ai jamais perdu confiance en moi
et beaucoup d'expérience beaucoup de
voyages et grâce à ça j'ai appris à
parler à toutes les langues sauf le grec
et voilà et puis après ça fait qui je
suis aujourd'hui et grâce à ça j'ai eu
cette opportunité extraordinaire qui est
d'être arrivée en mls
donc la mls c'est pas du tout un choix
par défaut pour vous non après c'était
une opportunité à saisir une opportunité
j'ai essayé beaucoup de choses en europe
et j'avais un manque de stabilité
en arrivant dans des clubs où il y avait
des installations qui étaient vraiment
pas professionnel et donc en gros la
perfection des états unis qui est
professionnel à tous les niveaux quand
c'est arrivé
j'aime pas hésité une seconde donc vous
êtes arrivé à kansas city
c'est là que tout a démarré en fait au
final ouais quand ça s'est il donc
j'arrive donc les
le pense au mercato d'hiver 2010 2011
les entraîneurs de de kansas y sont
venus me voir jouer aux particuliers
contre porto et nacional madère où
j'avais fait des très bons matches
ils sont venus et m'ont dit vous avez
supervisé avant oui bien sûr bien sûr et
ils sont nuit mon fer le contrat et et
vous savez à la règle de la fifa qu'on
vous avez trop matin salaire vous pouvez
casser le contrat donc ce qui ce qui
m'est arrivé
et après je suis parti aux états unis le
rêve américain a commencé et vous avez
pris le numéro 78 en référence aux
yvelines voilà exactement le gardien
fleury
je sais versailles donc et une grande
grande partie de ma vie donc en hommage
aux yvelines où ai-je après 78 et
comment vous trouvez le niveau de la mls
du coup vous qui avez un petit peu
voyagé un peu partout au niveau est
plutôt correct bacon en comparant
mes équipes de la mls et toutes les
équipes que j'ai fait en europe l'été
meilleur quand city on était meilleur
qu'eux au portugal que en écosse
après c'est sûr on espagnole à majorque
que j'ai joués il y avait des très
grands joueurs à majorque duo tristane
il va grâce à ave a longuement y avait
des très bons termes après bien sûr le
niveau de majorque était meilleure mais
non un niveau technique physique surtout
physique extraordinaire
après niveau tactique c'est ça évolue
chaque année
et donc c'est moi je peux pas comparer
avec avec l'europe parce que chaque
championnat ses caractéristiques mais un
bon niveau dans lequel j'ai progressé
j'ai travaillé donc la saison dernière
vous avez quitté quant à city pour
orlando pourquoi ce choix c'était
c'était un choix on va dire que vous
avez peut-être fait le tour vous avez
gagné plusieurs trophées notamment et
quant à city notamment le trophée de
meilleur joueur de la finale
c'était peut-être la fin d'un cycle
il fallait relancer un peu votre envie
de jouer pour le coude dans la veine s
où ça s'est fait comme ça pour revenir
en fin de contrat c'est en fin de
contrat après la mls c'est la règle des
lois il ya plein de drogue juste en fin
de contrat mais malgré ça si le club
donc quand ça s'est il m'offrait un
nouveau contrat à plus de 5%
c'est comme si activé une cinquième
année donc j'étais en fin de contrat
mais ce n'est pas gratuit et fin d'un
cycle oui je pense que kansas city c'est
des équipes à l'art auxerre certains
enfin saint-etienne con con énorme un
énorme pouvoir niveau de la formation
mais après pour aller plus au fond il
faut partir de ce club et orlando qui
était une nouvelle franchise mais avec
de grosses grosses ambitions
j'ai eu cette opportunité donc je suis
parti à orlando et ça a été une très
bonne initiative parce que roland doigts
c'est un gros club bat américain c'est
un gros club 2 mondial qu'on fait venir
kaka et condé gros gros gros moyens donc
je suis très content de la descente j'ai
pris justement kaka le brésilien joue
avec un ballon d'or voilà c'est ça rêve
c'est un rêve c'est magnifique une
personne extraordinaire humble très
professionnel et après techniquement
meilleur que tout le monde donc ça fait
progresser et vous avez des liens avec
lui enfin vous
vous êtes coéquipiers coéquipiers mais
mamie peut-être encore du temps non
amine ans qu'on est tous les deux
chrétien croyant
ensuite chacun son cercle d'amis où on
se respecte et on est coéquipiers mais
après on dort on n'est pas mais pas plus
que ça a mis non vous êtes collègues on
est que là exactement de travail et
votre jeu finalement vous êtes défenseur
ou les spécialistes vous disent assez
rugueux dur sur l'homme
vous êtes d'accord avec eux oui je suis
un défenseur au sens propre du terme
après j'aime beaucoup le ballon donc
quand on peut jouer je joue quand on
peut pas jouer cela dégage et j'aime
beaucoup le compact et un vrai un vrai
défenseur central et vous vous prenez
quelques cartons aussi de temps en temps
un badge jeu j'ai mûri première année
chez arriver j'en avais 13 donc j'étais
le enfin le meilleur je vais pas dire le
meilleur mais le joueur qui avait le
plus de cartons cette année en 2011 et
là maintenant j'ai pris que j'ai pris
deux rouges et seulement un jaune donc
on voit la progression de paix 2011 et
vous avez aussi un excellent jeu de tête
vous avez marqué une quinzaine de buts
en quatre saisons avec quant à city way
un petit peu plus un petit peu moins
cette année
pour l'instant c'est sale et seulement
deux buts seulement deux buts après je
marque beaucoup ses emplettes et
dans les matchs clés pour elle a
exactement on pourra se poser tout le
temps 2 3 4 mais bon c'est sûr au niveau
défensif
mon point fort c'est le jeu de tête mais
j'essaye quand je peux mettre un petit
coup de tête sur un corner ça fait
plaisir et vous êtes considéré comme
l'un des meilleurs défenseurs de la
ligue principalement grâce à ce jeu de
tête en six voix c'est possible et du
coup ce palmarès s'est construit petit à
petit vous avez été élu meilleur joueur
de la finale en 2013
vous avez gagné aussi une coupe aussi à
l'écran à city en 2012 c'est ainsi je
vous trompez votre palmas finalement a
pris du temps à se garnir mais il garnit
petit à petit
exactement beaucoup de travail beaucoup
de sacrifices et ça a payé à mes 25 ans
et donc c'est pour ça que petit à petit
moi ma carrière là quand elle a débuté
plus tard que la plupart des joueurs de
football
donc j'ai 29 ans aujourd'hui encore très
jeune à l'intérieur à l'extérieur et
donc je suis parti là bas en espérant un
jour peut-être revenir au meilleur
niveau en europe
ou alors faire ma carrière 100 % aux
etats-unis là je suis marié avec une
femme du venezuela et donc les rapports
sont faits très proches au venezuela
peut-être un jour représenter la
sélection du venezuela et j'ai créé mon
petit monde aux états unis donc en
vivant le l'american dream
mais en même temps on ne jamais oublier
mais mes racines et aimons 78 et donc
voilà après on verra ce que le futur me
réserve donc pas forcément la sélection
française
j'ai déjà eu des contacts avec eux
l'idée les chants ont pas du tout rien
du tout j'ai quitté la france des 19 ans
où ça fait dix ans
aujourd'hui même j'étais beaucoup plus
rapproché à cheveux pour les états unis
enfin quand je suis parti en 2011 mon
coach imeem paraît de la sélection des
états unis après au niveau du coeur les
états unis et moi en bas au niveau des
racines des cultures c'est un petit peu
différent et là maintenant ça fait cinq
ans que que venez sur la scène ma
deuxième maison donc on verra ce qui se
passera en fait j'ai donc pas contact
non plus avec le venezuela pendant ce
temps là si les contacts pour simon
table de contact beaucoup de contacts et
et donc nos qu'on verra et vous avez été
reçu par à la maison blanche et barack
obama faisait un petit peu chambré sur
sur votre costume je crois ce jour-là il
parlait des choses des accomplissements
des des joueurs en dehors du football et
il apparaît même arrivé vêtements et de
l'ammoniac laquelle les était habillée
avec mon costard c'était marrant une
petite vanne et moi ça fait beaucoup de
bruit et si on faisait beaucoup d'eux en
france à rester bas c'était un honneur
de rencontrer barack obama il est très
charismatique et après on peut être en
désaccord avec sa politique mais c'était
une très belle expérience qu'un français
repasse états unis de gaza montrent que
vous êtes pleinement aussi intégrer
aussi maintenant aux états unis entre
voilà le spécialiste qui qui appelle
parler de vous barack obama le l'autre
le trophée votre marque de vêtements
aussi donc vous êtes vraiment pleinement
intégré maintenant c'est comme vous dit
tout à l'heure c'est finalement le rêve
américain
ouais bien sûr ça fait cinq ans en vue
aux états unis donc il ya une part de
moi qui est américaine après j'ai des
goûts - la gastronomie et et beaucoup
enfin beaucoup de choses états unis ce
me ressemble pas trop à presse et les
états unis qui m'ont donné cette
opportunité au niveau du football donc
on a vu un grand merci à ce pays on va
parler de l'avenir maintenant orlando ou
médecine y est pour cette saison faisait
signer c'est mon année à orlando
est ce que vous comptez y rester encore
quelques années ou es ce que vous avez
encore jusqu'à deux objectifs peut-être
de revenir en europe par exemple nos
objectifs je suis parti aux états unis
pour trouver une stabilité et un
encadrement très professionnel les
américains sont très professionnels
perfectionniste et donc c'était
exactement ce que je recherchais même
avec des installations
ah oui c'est un autre monde et même au
niveau du suivi à tous les niveaux et
donc là maintenant je suis au au pic de
ma carrière 29 30 31 pour un défenseur
central
et j'ai encore un an de contrat donc on
va voir moi je ne me prends pas la tête
je travaille à fond c'est de faire les
meilleurs matchs que je peux et puis
c'est une opportunité qui vient on verra
l'ambiance d'un stade européen ça ça
vous donne
envie non voici au final l'ambiance aux
états unis est quand même à comme ça
s'est-il sympathique kansas city on
avait un stade high tech comme on dit
avec des choses qui est extraordinaire à
l'intérieur du stade et à l'extérieur
20000 personnes soldats faut pour 75
matchs de suite non on y voyait ambiance
et là on nous enfume 1 40 milles de
moyenne le programmation était à 62
milles à orlando notre nom j'ai envie
rien à l'europe
après c'est sûr si on compare avec le
real madrid barcelone et liverpool
chelsea et les mercredis européens bien
sûr mais faut rester au niveau donc d'un
club moyen de deux premières divisions
non j'ai rien à envier et mais après on
c'est sûr que je suis parti là-bas pour
travailler et revenir plus fort si un
jour je remets prêts aux états unis j'ai
j'ai vraiment un statut très bien donc
on l'a ainsi une opportunité bien et
c'est quelque chose que je recherche
depuis je suis tout petit comme une
bonne libyen
un club de premier league de bundesliga
c'est sûr que je réfléchirai
mais sinon je suis très bien où je suis
et très concentré avec un nouveau globe
avec beaucoup de moyens et une ambition
énorme donc la ligue 1 c'est possible
oui bien sûr bien sûr la ligue - la
france la moitié de mon coeur elle est
française donc ça serait un rêve
et est-ce qu'il ya un club qui vous fait
rêver en particulier en france ça moi je
suis paribas femmes à fontenay soixante
dix huit c'est paris après ça nous fait
rêver depuis que je suis tout petit
depuis tout petit avec fontenay avec fc
versailles on joue contre paris
saint-germain qu'aujourd'hui par paris
saint germain s'est livrée à madrid donc
pour aller jouer là bas faux je sais que
j'aurai un premier stade enfin d'aller
dans un club un petit peu plus au niveau
du statut un petit peu plus bas que pdg
après si je suis très performant aller
au psg mais non ainsi au psg c'est le
rêve de tout parisien
et puis on est très fiers enfin que ça
fait longtemps que la france n'avait pas
un club qui représentait la manne aux
états unis tome on part du psg donc ça
fait plaisir donc une association au vin
aurélien collin thiago silva
peut-être l'année prochaine au psg
pourquoi pas beaucoup de respect thiago
silva pour moi c'est un c est le
meilleur défenseur au monde donc à
beaucoup de respect donc je vais à ses
côtés ça ça doit être très sympathique
merci orignal colin merci à vous on
continuera à vous suivre évidemment la
saison prochaine en mls est dense et
huit sports on en parlera régulièrement
merci beaucoup rien qu'à l'inversé